JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've learned
a little bit about the dot
product, and how
the dot product can
be used to compute
angles between vectors,
or the relationship between
the dot product of vectors
and the angle between them.
So, here I have two questions,
two related questions for you.
So the first one,
you've got two vectors.
i hat plus j hat plus 2 k hat.
And a second vector, 2 i
hat minus j hat plus k hat.
I'm probably going to stop
saying the hats in a minute,
just warning you.
So you've got these
two different vectors,
and what I'd like to know is
what the angle between them is.
And the second one is
that we have three points.
So the P has coordinates
a, 1, and minus 1.
Q has coordinates 0, 1, and 1.
And R has coordinates
a, minus 1, and 3.
So when you've
given three points,
that define some angles.
So what I'd like to know
is for which values of a
is the angle PQR a right angle?
So why don't you take some
time, work out these problems,
come back, and we can
work them out together.
Hopefully you had some
luck on these problems.
Let's get started.
Let's start with the first one.
So we have these two vectors, i
plus j plus 2k, and 2i minus j
plus k.
And we want to know
what the measure
of the angle between them is.
So the thing that
we have to use here,
is that for vectors
v and w, we know
that v dot w can
be written in terms
of the angle between them.
So in particular, we know
that for vectors v and w,
if the angle between
them is equal to theta,
then cosine of theta
is equal to v dot w,
but I have to divide
by the length of v
and the length of w.
So I have this simple
formula for cosine
of theta in terms of v and w.
And so then if we
want, we can find theta
by taking an arccosine.
So let's apply this formula
in the case of problem a.
So we could say that v is
equal to i plus j plus 2k,
and w is equal to
2i minus j plus k.
And so what that means is that
in our case, v dot w-- well,
we just take, you know,
the products of the
coordinates and add them up.
So in that case, this is 1
times 2 plus 1 times minus 1
plus 2 times 1.
So this is 1 times 2 plus 1
times minus 1 plus 2 times 1.
So that's 2 minus 1 plus
2, so that's equal to 3.
And so then we also need to
know what the length of v and w
are in order to
apply this formula.
So the length of v is
equal to-- well it's
the square root of the sum of
the squares of the coordinates,
or the square root of v dot
v. So in this case, that's
the square root of 1 squared
plus 1 squared plus 2 squared.
So that's the square root of 6.
And the length of w
is equal to-- it's
the square root of 2
squared plus minus 1
squared plus 1
squared, which is also
equal to the square root of 6.
So if you put these
three things together,
we have that cosine
of theta is equal--
so I'm going to write
it right up here
next to this
general formula just
to save a little bit of
space-- so in our case,
this is equal to 3 divided
by the square root of 6
times the square root of 6.
So that's 3 divided by
6, which is equal to 1/2.
So if cosine of theta
is equal to 1/2,
well we know that
that means that theta
is equal to pi over 3.
OK?
So the angle between these
two vectors is pi over 3.
OK, great.
That's part a.
Now let's talk about part b.
So we have these
three points and we
want to know for what values
is the angle that they
define a right angle.
For what values
of this parameter.
Right?
Our points depend on
this parameter, a.
So in order to do that, we have
these three points in space.
Let me draw a picture up here.
So we have point P somewhere
and point Q somewhere and point
R somewhere, and they
define this angle,
and we want to know when
this angle is a right angle.
Well, we don't have
any vectors yet,
but it's easy to get
some vectors involved
in this problem.
We can look at the
vectors QP and QR.
So those two vectors
are the two sides
of this angle that
we're interested in.
And it's easy when you're given
coordinates for points to find
the vector between them.
So you just subtract, right?
So QP.
In order to get from
our point Q over here--
in order to get from (0,
1, 1) to (a, 1, -1)-- well,
you have to increase the first
coordinate by a, the second
coordinate has to stay the same,
and the third coordinate has
to decrease by 2.
So this vector QP is
equal to [a, 0, -2].
So now I'm using angle brackets,
because this is a vector.
SPEAKER 1: Positive
2 or negative 2?
JOEL LEWIS: Negative 2.
Yes.
Right.
Negative 2, yeah?
Because we're going
from 1 to minus 1.
OK, good.
And similarly QR.
So to get from Q to R-- I
have to go back and look
at the coordinates
over here-- so I
increase the first
coordinate by a,
decrease the second
coordinate by 2,
increase the third coordinate
by 2, to get from Q to R.
So the vector QR is equal to
a-- what did I say-- minus 2, 2.
So these are the
vectors QP and QR,
and we want to know when the
angle between these two things
is a right angle.
We want to know when these
vectors are perpendicular.
OK?
So the two vectors are
perpendicular exactly when
their dot product is 0.
Right?
When the angle is 90 degrees.
Cosine of 90 degrees,
cosine of pi over 2 radians,
is equal to 0, so those
two things are the same.
The dot product equals 0
and the angle is 90 degrees.
So OK.
So in our case, we just have
to look then at QP dot QR.
So that's equal to-- well,
we just take this dot product
here-- so it's equal to a
squared plus-- 0 times minus 2
is 0-- minus-- 2 times 2,
so plus minus 2 times 2-- so
that's minus 4.
So that's a squared minus 4.
And so this dot
product is equal to 0
exactly when a squared
minus 4 is equal to 0.
So a squared minus 4 is equal
to 0 when a is equal to 2
or when a is equal to minus 2.
So there are two
values of a for which
those three points form
a right angle at Q.
So just to quickly summarize, we
used this general formula here
for the cosine of an angle
in terms of the two vectors
that are the sides of the angle.
And with that formula, we
can compute the measure
of angles between
two vectors as here--
or, as in the first
part, in part a.
Or in a special case when we're
looking for a 90 degree angle,
we can use the simplified
form when we just
need to figure out when the
dot product is equal to 0.
OK.
So I'll end there.